this is looking or not yeah hello and
welcome to this video while this is
earlier looking at three it is but
strange how the software reacted here
anyway so I hope these 18 seconds will
make a difference so we get a king
lenient by a transposition and let's see
what else is playing
[Music]
inserting 86 is making sense normally to
make sure that the bishop is not
retreating to e3 at a proper a proper
moment 986 now is the most commonly see
move why is taking a while them for
those well-known theoretical move so
yeah Queen d8 Bishop d7 repeat this is
what is normally done him towards the
deer still be 3a three before so a 3h
five now is the the normal move please
or now
h5 for Bishop h6 is the normal way of
playing it you have to do this now as g5
was it mother said three so him how do
you play this Ruby one black is able to
play there should be three here put the
bishop even on c5 one idea that one has
is the night a 2 and then before we'll
see so here night a tour I can also take
I know that this is taking is probably
correct I don't quite remember I checked
this please sorry my voice is a bit off
I checked this only recently with the
student and we came to the conclusion
that white is fine so do i do that or I
can also try to put the light on on the
other side here night a two for B fourth
also an option
won't be one shooting form my deaf one
let's try that tonight f 133 would be
great if I can manage that maybe maybe
can play we should be three here pinning
the night but then i'll go g three ok
for it seems like i'm getting this from
getting this plate I wonder after Knight
g4 I can all I can just take this also
just take the night has meant a 93 a bit
surprised he takes a long time in
well I'm saying 93 next move that's
that's that's what I know take it now
this is 93 have
number Bishop here somehow is blocking
everything quite nicely on the kingside
are not getting attacked there anytime
soon he is probably just going to lose
this on time
[Music]
I'm not sure what the best continuation
is for me night each who and before
looks very normal and I think I'm going
for that you can try the Queen g6 book h
eight and then sec the exchange that's
definitely an idea but you better do it
quickly but he just is he's just letting
the clock run out I mean it's not nice
for blacks but play something
yeah night to d3 is that coming up might
be I can take the tick the night and
then check on his heaven but so I didn't
look don't look extremely clear to this
if five hang seven and then the time is
there is an issue mangled on what they
prefer Jeff they were a pretty weird way
of spending your time I mean this is a
theoretical position that's the first
thing and he took a long time to to play
into that I think at five takes takes a
force is well known and this now it's
okay the engine is before hmm wow did
not think about that what how does that
work will be scream that's a very
computer ish variation like this book is
coming potentially there it looks good
yeah looks good interesting ok I played
this one and here taking I'm not in sure
this is right yeah the engine actually
is quite critical about it which i think
is a bit surprising I'm absolutely
certain that i'm not worth in this
position I mean how can wipe us here I
don't get it
[Music]
amal oh that stunned because I
absolutely cannot believe that I'm worth
in this version and even clearly worse
according to the engine so how does that
work it wants to play Queen here what is
this what's the idea okay I it's a
tactical idea Bishop takes a three is
the thing but let's say i'll go here
what what then b5 yeah yeah well okay
this is not what i wanted to do yeah
maybe that's absolutely true this is the
same tweenage aid as strong it threatens
this because my night is loose our
singing during the game i can just
slowly improve but there is nothing this
is the thing if there's nothing that
happens slowly be five is coming and
that kid I mean taking is pretty
questionable and there are all kinds of
threats hmm that's interesting I was
thinking Amber's I'm better I mean at
least a little bit a king of heavenly
this distance to
much yeah by know it was clear that I
was being on time so didn't look all
that hard this is this is quite amazing
that it did not really like is better
with this may it's very concrete I mean
if I have to move the 90th NB 5 is
coming and then like it's very very much
better and clearer so I probably
misplayed this part of the game here
somewhat Bishop takes you form doesn't
seem to be right interesting yeah ok
guys thanks for watching